>> Laura: WELCOME BACK.
TIME FOR, WE NEED A THING,
FRIDAY FOLLIES.
WE NEED A THING.
WE START WITH A CHAIRMAN OF
STARBUCKS ANNOUNCING A NEW
BATHROOM POLICY FOR ALL ITS
STORES.
WHAT COULD POSSIBLY GO WRONG?
HERE TO EXPLAIN IT RAYMOND
ARROYO.
>> REMEMBER THOSE TWO
AFRICAN-AMERICAN MEN, NOW HE HAS
ANNOUNCED A NEW POLICY.
>> WE DON'T WANT TO BECOME A
PUBLIC BATHROOM, BUT WE ARE
GOING TO MAKE THE RIGHT DECISION
A HUNDRED PERCENT OF THE TIME
AND GIVE PEOPLE THE KEY.
WE DON'T WANT ANYONE TO FEEL AS
IF WE ARE NOT GIVING ACCESS TO
YOU TO THE BATHROOM BECAUSE OUR
LESS THAN.
WE WANT YOU TO BE MORE THAN.
>> Laura: LET ME GET IT
STRAIGHT.
WHEN YOU GO RUNNING ON THE MALL,
YOU GET THE DRINKING FOUNTAINS,
WHEN I WAS TRAINING FOR THE
MARATHON YEARS AGO, PEOPLE WOULD
BE CLEANING THEIR SOCKS.
SO YOU WERE DESPERATE FOR WATER.
THEN YOU SEE SOMEONE CLEANING
THEIR SOCKS.
YOU DON'T WANT TO DRINK WHEN THE
SOCKS ARE RUNG OUT.
>> WE ARE NOT GOING TO BE A
PUBLIC BATHROOM, BUT YOU ARE.
YOU ARE GIVING THE KEYS TO
EVERYBODY.
I HAVE SPOKEN TO STARBUCKS
MANAGERS.
THEY SAY IT'S A HEALTH NUISANCE.
THEY HAVE TO GO WITH THE HAZMAT
OUTFITS TO CLEAN OUT THESE
THINGS.
THEY CLEAN ARTICLES AND CLEAN
THEMSELVES.
YOU ATTRACT THE HOMELESS AND
DRIVE AWAY.
>> Laura: TIME TO GO TO PETE'S.
>> RATHER THAN HAVING THIS 8,000
STORE UNCONSCIOUS BIAS TRAINING
AT THE END OF MAY, THE BETTER IS
PUT PUBLIC STALLS, THEN YOU
COULD CALL THAT UNCONSCIOUS
COMMON SENSE.
>> Laura: I JUST LIKE WHAT HE
SAID, WE DON'T WANT YOU TO FEEL
LIKE YOU ARE LESS THAN.
WE WANT YOU TO BE MORE THAN.
THAT'S A DEEP THOUGHT.
WE GOT MAD MAXINE.
MAXINE WATERS, WE HAVE TO PLAY,
SHE WAS UPSET ABOUT --
>> THIS IS AN OBAMA ERA,
ANTI-RACISM THING FOR CAR
DEALERSHIPS.
THE REPUBLICANS REPEALED IT, SHE
WENT ON A TEAR.
>> WE ARE TRYING TO MAKE SURE WE
ARE MAKING AMERICA GREAT EVERY
DAY AND EVERY WAY.
THE BEST WAY TO DO THAT IS STOP
TALKING ABOUT DISCRIMINATION AND
START TALKING ABOUT THE NATION.
WE ARE COMING TOGETHER IN SPITE
OF WHAT YOU SAY.
>> MR. KELLEY PLEASE DO NOT
LEAVE, I WANT YOU TO KNOW I AM
MORE OFFENDED THAN YOU WILL EVER
BE.
THIS BUSINESS ABOUT MAKING
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN, IT IS YOUR
PRESIDENT THAT'S DIVIDING THIS
COUNTRY.
I RECENT THE MARK ABOUT MAKING
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN, HE'S MAKING
A SPEECH FOR THIS DISHONNABLE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
I RESERVE THE BALANCE OF MY
TIME.
I DO NOT YIELD, NOT ONE SECOND
TO YOU.
NOT ONE SECOND TO YOU.
>> Laura: I LOVE IT.
>> I'M NOT YIELDING A SEC TO
>> I'M NOT YIELDING A SECONO
>> I'M NOT YIELDING A SECOND TO
YOU.
>> Laura: IT'S THE BAG.
>> I WISH SHE WOULD GET ENGAGED
AND COLLABORATE.
SHE AGREES ON SOME ISSUE.
WORK WITH THEM.
FLOOD INSURANCE, HEALTHCARE.
SHE CAN FIND THINGS.
>> Laura: THAT LITTLE ACT, THAT
WAS DISHONORABLE.
THAT WAS LAME.
>> HOUSE RULES.
>> Laura: WE GOT RACIST LEGOS.
>> MEGAN MARKLE, THEY HAVE
CREATED A LEGO, THEY ARE SAYING
IT'S RACIST.
SHE HAS THE SAME SKIN TONE AS
PRINCE HARRY.
I STUDIED AND FOUND PEOPLE
SAYING THE INCREDIBLE HULK WAS
LIME GREEN IN HIS LEGO
DEPICTION.
HE'S LIME GREEN AND IN THE MOVIE
HE'S DARK GREEN.
WE NEED TO BE CONSISTENT.
LEGO HAS BEEN CHARGED WITH
RACISM IN THE PAST.
THERE WAS A JOB PLAY SET.
HE SMOKED A HUKA AND THAT WAS A
PROBLEM.
SO THEY WERE
SO THEY RERE
SO THEY RECE
SO THEY RECALLED THAT.
THEY ARE DOING A FOX SET OF PLAY
SETS.
THE INGRAHAM ANGLE IS IT.
THIS IS FROM THE COLLECTION.
WE'LL PUT IT UP ON THE SCREEN.
THIS IS YOU AND I.
JUST LOOK.
>> WHY DO I HAVE ORANGE HAIR AND
YOU HAVE BIG EARS?
I LOOK LIKE TRUMP.
>> I'M UPSET ABOUT THESE DEPICKS
BECAUSE MY EARS LOOK NOTHING
LIKE THAT.
YOU ARE A LITTLE LIGHTER.
>> I'M FINDING THAT.
THERE IS INHERENT BIAS AND
IMPLICIT BIAS AGAINST NATURAL
BLONDES.
>> I TAKE BACK THE BALANCE OF MY
TIME.